I did cry floods floods of ten it's one
of the most famous scenes in cinematic
history playing
but it's not as simple as it looks and
only et has the story behind the
stunning moment why don't we take a look
[Music]
Titanic is arguably one of the most
important movies of all time partially
because James Cameron's aquatic epic has
no shortage of iconic moments when I
first saw myself on screen when it was
that there's a top shot of me in the big
purple hat and look up at the camera
leather I just thought what am i doing
in this film I mean that's not that's
not really me while Kate Winslet and
Leonardo DiCaprio's characters only
share a few days together jacket roses
romance is one of movie history's
all-time greatest love stories so you
want to go to a real party the love
story I knew was gonna be what the
audience was connected to you know the
first two hours is mainly about these
two characters and becoming emotionally
attached to them and that's why the
tragedy is you know so powerful at the
end so how did Cameron tell such a
powerful love story in that short amount
of time well you can think that one
famous scene
give me your hand in a movie full of
groundbreaking visual effects some
real-life magic was actually at played
during that breathtaking moment we had
an incredible luck with that sunset I
mean literally we got up there and we
thought well this will just be a good
rehearsal for us and we'll have to shoot
it another day and at the last second
the clouds kind of parted and some was
going down it was a beautiful sky and so
the sky that you see is the sky that we
shot as soon as she saw the sunset
Winslet snapped into action on set and
this beautiful sunset started to happen
and Kate was up there and she was
screaming down at us you know I think at
the camera shoot had shooted you know
Leo was running up there and they came
together and we had very little time to
rehearse and then you see the final
thing and and it's it's really extremely
it does take your breath away
it certainly took mine away when I saw
in this scene also became the icon of
Titanic's mega successful marketing
campaign the movie set a new box office
record grossing 1.8 billion dollars
worldwide we expected it to be something
I had no idea what we knew this
magnitude I mean it's truly overwhelming
and scored 11 wins at the Academy Awards
as with all famous movie moments has
also been countless reenactments even by
the stars themselves
[Music]
why all-in-all Cameron help close out
cinemas first century with a scene that
will well go on forever it was just one
of those magical moments that happens
you know once in a movie maybe once in a
lifetime
[Music]